it's a full-on mutiny against president
biden as democrats in the media ramp up
the pressure to stop biden from running
in 2024
democratic voters repulsed by the
president's performance a new york times
poll shows 64 percent do not want biden
as their nominee and 94 percent of
democrats under the age of 30 said they
prefer a different candidate the times
publishing a stunning report about how
staffers quote quietly watch out for
biden during his trips to the beach and
are very worried about his age quote
he often shuffles when he walks and
aides worry he will trip on a wire he
stumbles over words during public events
and they hold their breath to see if he
makes it to the end without a gaff
and it's not just a liberal media taking
notice former obama adviser david
axelrod pointing out that the president
just doesn't have what it takes to get
his message across to voters
when democrats chose joe biden when joe
biden was elected he was elected for the
very things that he's been criticized
for he was elected because he was
considered a calm conciliatory figure
when he tries people say why isn't he
you know more angry uh out there when he
tries to do that uh you know he comes
across like uh clint eastwood and gran
torino chasing kids off the lawn it's
not a good look that's not who he is
and how reassuring kamala harris giving
a curiously worded response to who will
be on the ticket in 2024
listen to president biden he intends
to run
and
if he does i intend to run with him
so there you go
jesse i'm going to start with you we
knew
in december
if not before then that this trouble was
that this president was in huge trouble
now having known that we knew it they
definitely knew what they're polling
every minute i'm sure
how dumb are they that they couldn't
figure out some way
to get back and to try to get some of
these numbers or groups to support them
well
judge if i were advising the biden white
house they would have turned this around
by now because it's pretty simple you
just try to do everything you can to
lower gas prices and that'll solve
everything but they haven't done that
the fact that this drops in the sunday
edition of the times biggest circulation
they follow up with the one-two combo
the monday story on the polling that was
designed for maximum impact because
everybody in the liberal media they wake
up in their miserable apartments they
open the new york times and they see
this is what i'm going to do on the show
today so this is the new york times
telling the rest of the press
the biden protection racket is over stop
circling the wagons we can tell the
truth now and it didn't take the
afghanistan situation or gas prices or
immigration inflation it took joe biden
after they brought down the case from
the
supreme court about roe
he shrugged his shoulders and flew to
delaware now they wanted to him to show
up to kavanaugh's house with a bullhorn
they wanted him to chain himself to a
planned parenthood when they say he
didn't meet the moment that's what they
mean he didn't
release a primal scream
and that's what the base expected so
when they opened up the paper on sunday
they must have been confused the readers
it sounded like a jesse waters primetime
monologue the guy can't talk he can't
walk and not only that
the supporting quotes from the white
house staff were just as bad they were
like oh well sometimes when he gets into
air force one he doesn't fall asleep
right away or you know actually the
president sometimes helps write his own
speeches and and sometimes in meetings
he actually asks questions in meetings
so but what did it for me is when they
said that they had to break up those
overseas trips because he needed to rest
he should have gone to europe and then
just jaunted south to the mideast in one
shot but they had to have him fly back
here and rest for three weeks now if he
can't do that how's he supposed to run
for president when you're zigzagging all
over the country going from fundraiser
to speech to white house event he's not
going to be able to physically do it and
that was the most revealing thing for me
but the thing is he hid in his basement
last time and i'll think of a reason for
him to hide in the basement this time i
could see that dana you're chomping at
them i've got so
um
so
the other quote that you we haven't
mentioned yet was one that was on the
record from kate bettingfield she's the
outgoing communications director and one
of the things she did on her way out is
to take a shot at democratic activists
who are asking for president biden to do
things that are
useless which is like taking a bull horn
and going to kavanaugh's house so that
they can say well he really fights and
he's really angry they're not trying to
persuade anybody there's no creativity
in the policy process there's no
figuring out okay what are the 10 states
that we want to make sure that we focus
on these 10 we don't have to worry about
because abortion is going to be fine
these 10 states little iffy those 10
states we got to figure out something
there there's just no policy process
creativity and she said
basically to the woke activists that
you're not even in the democratic
mainstream so now they have lost
independence
progressives
hispanics
and the youth and i just want to mention
one thing on the youth they're not
necessarily the most um reliable voting
group but they mattered in this past
election when biden put together a
pretty impressive coalition of the
willing even if it was hold your nose
and vote for him so that they could try
to beat trump now you have the youth for
example amongst the 18 to 29 year olds
only five percent of them
want the party to renominate joe biden
and then you have somebody like mayor
pete who says on air that they want
pilots who are over 65 to retire
because they want a new generation they
want
off with the baby boomers when we have a
pilot crisis when we have a problem
every airport is basically dealing with
all of these delays and you need every
pilot that you can get they're playing
the age card on these guys um when my
last point is biden was only two one
years old when harry truman took office
and in his lifetime we've completely
lost the idea that the buck stops
at the white house and now is now
they're not even blaming putin anymore
they're full on just trying to blame
republicans
you know i'll tell you harold i see you
made a lot of notes this is this is
everybody's getting very excited here
but you know they say they're citing
biden's age as uh
as the most important reason why they
don't want him to run again i'm not so
sure if it's his age or if it's
literally his intellectual inability to
identify problems speak to problems i
mean the guy i mean i know people who
are that age who are a lot more vigorous
than he is henry kissinger just came out
a new book you haven't read it now you'd
like that book you said before his
book's pretty good on leadership as well
you're right judge
frame these problems and give us metrics
i hope that the white house processes
this poll with a sense of purpose and
humility
and takes the right things from it if
things were going better you wouldn't
have these numbers so if i were them the
four or five things quickly i try to get
my arms around and identify metrics
jesse's right energy is the key here if
you give certainty to the energy
companies if we can go and try to give
certainty to mbs which i happen to agree
with i understand the president's trip
here then you've got to give certainty
to our oil and energy companies here and
that those optics alone will give some
confidence to to to to everyday
americans who are struggling with these
high prices i might have prices have
come down a little bit on gasoline the
last two weeks about 20 hopefully we go
continue to go in that direction two
encourage congress to to pass the ch the
chips act this is the one thing that
republican and democratic governors are
like around the country particularly in
ohio need in order to ensure that the
investments that intel and the state of
ohio and the federal government are
going to make to ensure that we're able
to build semiconductor chips in america
so we can uh we can we can we can
better counter china and other things is
an important thing three every week we
ought to be updating the supply chain
you need to put that marty walsh out
there who i just love hearing talk the
labor secretary let them every week he
and the secretary of commerce tell us
what we're doing how we're doing it and
what more we need to be doing as a
country
four the border it's a national security
issue energy in the border i believe are
the two things if the president and this
team could frame and give us metrics we
report numbers every week on the show
about how high the the the cross rate is
across the border and how many people we
see numbers around fentanyl i'd have a
fentanyl task force every week i'd give
the country an update on what we're
doing to lower these numbers if all you
see are numbers that are going up that
are bad for the country and numbers
going down and bad for the country and
there's no confidence the country may
have it then finally
i'd make every republican running for
office every democrat that has every
republican running for office are you
for rape and insects
exception to abortion because i am and
if you ask those questions in the
present you got to do your part first we
might have a fighting chance in november
that's what i do look look everything
that you just said
any of us could have said that i mean it
was brilliant
[Laughter]
here's the bottom line on that
are they so uncaring that they couldn't
think to do any of those things and i'll
ask you tom
why didn't they address any of those
issues it's not that tough because they
don't want to and they they can't deal
with the idea they
not nobody thinks biden is running again
including the vice president who i think
i know her tell now uh when she's
bluffing and that's vigorous nodding of
the hedge he intends
to run and i intend to run with i want
to play poker with her
i'm raising you because i have four aces
[Laughter]
but uh i don't think that i i if i were
republicans let me give them advice i'm
not a a strategist but i would say don't
run on the you know he's out of touch he
has dementia he doesn't know where he is
he's he knows enough to ruin the country
he's hurting the country so talk about
what he's doing to hurt the country not
that he doesn't i don't want to give him
an out and say he doesn't know what he's
doing it's somebody else it's like no
it's him
yep it is all right coming up dems
openly mocking the safety of supreme
court justices as the radical left
offers bounties on their locations hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now